cette crise sanitaire a eu des
conséquences économiques désastreuses
des milliers de commerçants ont dû
fermer boutique à cause du confinement
certains n'ont pas pu s'en remettre et
ont fait faillite
d'autres manifestement ont pu profiter
de la pandémie puisque le confinement à
favoriser le shopping en ligne ces deux
cas d'amazon par exemple et bruno le
maire ne cesse de dénoncer ces géants du
numérique dans les faits c'est plutôt l
inverse on va ça avec un mona a model à
la face aux géants du numérique dont
amazon bruno le maire -ministre de
l'économie
hamouma le torse les géants du numérique
ce sont aujourd'hui les adversaires des
états la question de la lutte contre les
géants du numérique est une question pas
simplement économiques
elle est aussi politique sociale et
financière mais en octobre dernier les
137 membres de l' ocde avait échoué à
trouver un accord sur la fiscalité des
guerres femmes pour google apple
facebook amazon et microsoft en raison
d'un désaccord avec les états unis est
un des plus mauvais élèves et amazon
tantôt épinglé parce que l'entreprise ne
paye pas d'impôts en france ou pour les
mauvaises conditions travaillent dénoncé
par des salariés bref comme l'a dit
bruno le maire amazon serait un
adversaire de l'état le sauf qu'en poule
est si lent mais autrement selon
mediapart avant public
discrètement signé des accords avec
amazon un de ces accords lui donne un
accès partiel à des données de près de
550 mille entreprises françaises
éligible au prêt garanti par l'état le
géant américain de la vente en ligne a
lancé une plate-forme en france baptisée
l'accélérateur du numérique est présenté
comme je cite une nouvelle formation
gratuite au e-commerce conçu par des
experts du numérique une offre ciblant
les entrepreneurs font ces novices dans
le commerce en ligne ce qui offrirait
amazon un rôle central et un accès
privilégié au développement de ces
entreprises en partenariat
dénoncé par le directeur général de
l'afnic pierre bomis et le président du
syndicat des entrepreneurs sse innove
numérique alors a souvent faire des
grandes plateformes la solution aux
défis de la numérisation sans jamais
citer la possibilité de créer son propre
site et ainsi construire son autonomie
numérique c'est envoyer les tpe et pme
au casse pipe
le message doublement problématique
sous-entend que la solution est la
compétence numérique serait celle
d'amazon et que la numérisation des
commerces et des tpe pme passerait par
les marketplace américaines recommandées
amazon par défaut c'est faire preuve de
mépris pour les acteurs français et
ignorer la réalité de notre tissu
économique
le partenariat bpi amazon porte un
risque majeur dénier aux entreprises et
commerces le droit de choisir de changer
de faire jouer la concurrence
alors pour préserver l'indépendance
numérique de 16 entreprises la bonne
riposte et elle d'offrir aux géants
américains l'accès aux données
d'entreprise facilitant ainsi
l'extension de son influence en france
ce partenariat ne laisserait que très
peu de chance à d'autres sociétés
spécialisées dans l'accompagnement
digital de son côté l'union européenne
espère pouvoir proposer un projet de
taxation des gir
de l'internet en 2021